let's see let's go next to our caller
from the five for one area code who's
calling today from five for one that
would be me
actually great who's this my name is
Paul von Hartman I'm in Ashland Oregon
great yeah I well I just like to say I
agree with Dante briefly and I have an
idea for challenging the memo that keeps
the house from indicted a sitting
president that's what needs to be done
because the Senate by their oath of
objectivity and impartiality well hold
on Paul let's just back up one second if
we can
you're talking about you want the house
to criminally indict the president I
don't believe that's a power the house
even conceivably has well these are
extraordinary times where you know
people like Mitch McConnell and Lindsey
Graham are openly violating their oath
right to be impartial and so you know
extreme circumstances require
out-of-the-box thinking about how to
stop the slide into totalitarianism that
we're we're all watching happen I don't
disagree at all and I do think that the
idea of listening I know waiting to
November sounds like a long time and
then it's until January until the next
president would be inaugurated but know
that the house doesn't have the power to
criminally indict and I can assure you
whatever would need to be done in order
to make that even a remote possibility
is going to take longer than the eight
and a half months that remain between
now and the election so I think it's
important just to stay focused on what
are practical solutions are I'm it
sounds super interesting for the house
to indict someone but it's just not
going to happen and we can much more
quickly vote this guy out in November
there's no
that keeps them being bill bar though
sorry there's nothing that keeps what
about bar it there's nothing that
prevents the indictment of bill bar
they're involved in a conspiracy to
overthrow the US government I'm just not
all the house can criminally indict
anyone that so the House of
Representatives is a legislative body if
I'm speaking out of turn by all means
you know I'm willing to be corrected but
I don't think no matter what bill Barr
has done I don't believe the house has
the power to criminally indict people
well someone does I mean there must be
some it's the job system that's run by
overhaul well you know what I can hear
myself on spirited well I'm gonna have
to let you go cuz I'm hearing myself
back on a three second delay it's
getting a little crazy but I would just
vote in November that's much faster than
getting the house to indict anybody
which I just I just don't think they can
do as reasonable as the idea might be